Film Courage: Being the hot young writer,
being on the cover of Variety, your name is
out there, and probably your phone is ringing
a lot.
I know you’ve talked in other interview
about how some of this went away for a little
bit.
Can you talk about how if someone else is
in a similar situation, how they regroup?
Corey Mandell: What I’d like to do is give
the single best piece of advice that is most
forgotten, that is ignored.
And so what happened is when I was on the
front page of Variety and all these offers
were coming in, there was an agent at my agency
(Barbara Dreyfus), who didn’t represent
me, but she took me out to lunch and she gave
me the following advice.
She said “The next script you write is the
most important script you’ll ever write.
It will determine the trajectory of your career.
So right now you were an unknown person.
You are on everyone’s radar.
You worked with a high-profile director.
He’s planning on making the movie.
He said how great your script was.
Everyone in town wants to work with you.
Everyone is like so hyped up on you.”
Now there are like writers who are commodity
writers.
They go in and they write these summer movies
and these big action movies and they make
a lot of money.
But there is nothing special about them.
And then there are writers who are A-list
writers.
Writers who have these amazing careers.
The next script you write will put you on
a trajectory.
So her advice was this…don’t take any
job you wouldn’t have done for free which
was to say you love this project and you believe
you can just knock it out of the park.
You love this so much, you would do it without
getting paid.
Now we’re going to get you paid but don’t
take anything that falls short of that.
Just say no to a lot of stuff because most
of what they are going to offer is crap or
just not a good fit for you.
And the offers are going to start to slow
down and you are going to panic and think
you have to grab the next best one, don’t!
And the offers will keep slowing down and
I’m telling you this even…you’ll think
that the offers will eventually go away and
they won’t.
But even if they do, literally you’ve said
no to everything, spec your next script and
make it something that you love and knock
it out of the park.
Because she said if the next one is amazing,
that puts you on a trajectory, then people
see you a certain way.
Later on is the time to do it for money.
Later on we’ll grabble on for the money.
But not for this next script.
Now everyone knows who you are, the next script
is going to tell them what kind of writer
you are.
And when she said that, I had that chill up
my spine that this is absolutely true, I need
to hear this and do this.
And I said no to something, I said no to something.
The third time I said no was a Disney project
and they doubled my quote and I said no.
And they doubled my quote and I said yes.
And I’m embarrassed to say that that project
of all the projects was not only a script
I did not want to write, it was a movie I
wouldn’t even want to see.
I don’t come from money.
I had student debt and it was more money than
I ever thought you could make in years and
I was going to get paid for three months.
And so the precedent that I set (at least
for myself) was I’m in this for the money
and that really locked me into a career path.
It was I wish I could go back in time.
I feel like that was a really big test and
I failed it.
Film Courage: I could see where a lot of people
would not blame you and I’m not even sure
which project you’re referring to (forgive
me).
So you really feel like even the money that
you took, it probably changed many things
for you because money can do wonderful things
but it can also hurt some things.
Corey Mandell: But here’s the thing, if
I hadn’t taken that project and that project
never got made.
And as a writing sample I think it was good
but it wasn’t special.
If I had waited and waited and took something
else or even something original and even if
it was great, I would have made so much money
down the road.
So my agent represents me but he also represents
Aaron Sorkin.
I worked non-stop as a studio writer for 11
years.
I made a lot more money than I ever thought
I could make.
Do you know the difference between how much
money Aaron Sorkin is making…I don’t know?
But I’m sure that whatever Aaron Sorkin
makes is not even in the same zip code of
what I made.
He also represents J.K.
Rowling.
Now I’m not saying that I could have become
Aaron Sorkin or that level or that I could
have been J.K.
Rowling.
I don’t know.
But what I do know is that the choices I made
prevented that possibility.
I was a studio writer and I just started doing
a bunch of action movies, some were action
comedies.
Sometimes I thought they were fun, sometimes
I didn’t but I loved the paycheck.
And I loved just making the money and the
deal and I never stopped and wrote from my
heart.
And I’ll tell you one of the main reasons
was I was so fixed-mindset, I was so afraid
of rejection.
I was so afraid that people would say “Oh,
you’re not that good of a writer, you’re
a fraud.”
Now if I wrote something from my heart, if
I wrote something that exposed me to the material,
now you’re not a good writer and you’re
not even a good person.
Like they could reject me…if they rejected
my material and it was very personal, then
that would feel like they rejected me as a
person.
And that was too painful.
I was not going to allow that to happen.
My agent was begging me to write something
authentic and from the heart.
My wife was begging me, my manager was begging
me, my Golden Retriever was begging me and
I just wouldn’t.
So A) it was short-sighted.
First of all, money isn’t everything but
even if money is everything I potentially
could have made so much money.
But more importantly I could have written
stuff that I was in love with.
Look, I could have tried for that career.
I could have written authentic stuff.
I could have swung for the fences, I could
have tried for that A-list career and maybe
come up short.
And then backed into the career I had, maybe?
I don’t know.
But I know that the choices I made then, I
was never going to have that career.
I was never going to be creatively fulfilled.
I was never going to be writing the stuff
that I really wanted to be writing.
I was never going to be writing from love.
I was always going to be writing from fear.
I regret that.
And so part of the reason I teach is I want
to help writers do it the right way and help
empower them with the tools.
I wish someone had taught me creative integration
up front and some of the stuff.
But I hope that I can be an influence on writers
so that they can have the best possible career
that they are capable of, maybe even a better
one than that.
Film Courage: So if you were to take yourself
to lunch, instead of that women [the agent
Barbara] taking you to lunch and it was an
older you speaking to that younger you, would
you have said the exact same thing?
Corey Mandell: I would have and I would have
said “And look, I’m from the future so
let me tell you.”
And I would have told him all of the terrible
things that would have happened and I honestly
think that this younger me would have made
the same decision.
The reason is he was so fixed-mindset and
with fixed-mindset you are just working from
fear and you just can’t see the truth or
you can’t…and hopefully that is not true,
hopefully I would have.
But anyway, I’m not confident that I would
have made a different decision.
I’m not proud of that but I think that’s
the truth.
But I will say, my wife always sees the real
truth.
And one of the things you says is all the
things that happened in my career is actually
a blessing.
It softened me up.
It got me out of this fear space and I wouldn’t
be the teacher that I am now had I not made
those mistakes and gone through that.
And I did make a lot of money, which is nice.
So it’s like it had a lot of perks.
But yeah…I wish I could have done it differently.